welcome into another market takes on who
what what a report what a morning um we
are diving into all of this uh cpi we
are breaking down the consumer price
index report for may that came in a
sizzling scalding smoking hot 8.6
year-over-year i'm gonna break down what
that means why it's important um and and
there's a lot there's a lot to unpack so
we're gonna dive right into it this is a
special edition we are looking and
talking just about today's cpi consumer
price index report came out 8 30 we've
had about half an hour to digest it
markets have had about half an hour to
digest it and digest they have we are
saying big moves especially in the
treasury uh us bond market so we're
going to talk through all of that uh
what it means what we saw we're going to
dig into the report uh unpack all the
details for you and do all of that man
thank you for tuning in i am dionne
robowen reporter with the wall street
journal appreciate you guys being with
me i know you could have been anywhere
in the world instead you're here with me
so i appreciate that look let's let's
jump right into it 8.6
year over year for the cpi that means
inflation is rising faster in may than
it was in march march was when the fed
lots of economists said okay we hit this
8.5 percent mark we've peaked we're
going to be moving down from here
inflation should you know start to
slowly move down towards our two percent
target no throw all that out the window
inflation came down a little bit in
april 8.3 and then right back up to 8.6
higher than the previous peak last month
we are now back to the highest since
december 1981. if you watch if you tuned
in on monday i talked about how
historically we're on this move downward
if we follow the same trend as the last
time inflation was this high back in the
1980s inflation peaked at 15 and then it
moved down and once we hit 1982 which uh
april's april's reading was the highest
since 1982 we continued to move down
until we got to about two and a half
percent by 1983 and that was end of
summer towards the autumn of 1983. we
also had a recession in there uh you had
the fed raising rates to 19 to get
inflation down the fed right now still
uh only at about only less than one
percent uh interest rates are still less
than one percent
between point seven five and and one
percent uh we're going to have to i
think the fed's gonna have to get on its
horse and make some moves here so look
let's get into it inflation did not peak
in march that's the big takeaway um the
fed retired the word transitory remember
all the 2021 or most of 2021 they were
saying inflation will be transitory and
then in november they said we're going
to retire that word transitory uh and
and really just focus on doing our
business uh jerome powell now has some
splaining to do he's gonna have to talk
through okay not only was inflation not
transitory continued to rise higher and
higher but it looks like it hasn't
peaked and it looks like we could be
going back up
one big thing about the expectations i
have been talking to you guys about the
expectations for cpi the consumer price
index for a couple weeks now and again
inflation or expectations started around
7.2 percent there were expectations for
inflation to fall by about one percent a
little more than one percent then as we
got closer and closer as more economists
reported their predictions as more data
come in as more data came in and as as
you know gas prices continue to rise
food prices continue to rise all those
things you saw more economists start to
raise those predictions until today
before the cpi report they had rate
they'd gone from 7.2 to 8.1 to 8.2 to
today the expectations were for 8.3 as
high as april in may
and then we got boom even higher than
that
so we're going to talk through the
long-term implications of this report
the one word i have to say is wow
wow
inflation a lot higher than economists
were predicting so like i said cpi
highest since december 1981 want to read
you something from the bureau of labor
statistics
they put out this cpi report it's the
government agency responsible for all
that they say there was an
across-the-board increase a quote across
the board increase the increase was
broad-based with the indexes for shelter
gasoline and food being the largest
contributors
again that's
that tells you everything inflation is
everywhere it's not going away it's not
being reduced to just a few items it's
not just food and gas anymore the energy
index though up 34.6
year-over-year that's the largest
12-month increase since the period
ending september 2005. uh the food index
up 10.1 percent for the year uh the
first index the first increase of 10 or
more since march 1981 that means that
the food index is in the price of food
that's food generally you eat outdoor
prepare food sorry you eat outside the
home prepared food things like that
hadn't ever gone up this high
during this inflationary cycle that
we're seeing right now so march when cpi
peaked
uh food inflation still wasn't 10 it is
up over 10 now the highest since march
1981. we did see a decline a little bit
in car prices that's good so something
to look out for there if you look at the
housing index or the component of
housing what what uh people the bureau
of labor statistics call shelter the
index for all items less food and injury
that's the core index we're going to get
into that just a sec but the shelter
index increased 0.6 percent
that's the largest monthly increase
since march of 2004 so again the cost of
shelter whether you're renting owning
getting shelter somehow some way
up by the highest amount since march
2004 that means higher than we've seen
in previous months when inflation peaked
again
the the shelter reading was even higher
than that so we're seeing prices for
food prices for shelter aka rent and
your your house your home payment rising
by even faster paces than they were
we're seeing an acceleration and again
one percent increase in those prices uh
for
month-over-month cpi so the cpi rising
at one percent from the previous month
uh when again we were supposed to see
this general cooling trend
so want to talk about core inflation
because the fed when they're doing their
thing and remember everything right now
is all about the fed the federal reserve
and what they're going to do they like
to look at those core numbers right they
like to say okay energy food yeah yeah
yeah those those can jump around a lot
but what's the core doing well
core inflation was up by 0.6 in may
that's a significant increase and again
that's well above expectations uh month
over month the overall cpi increased by
one percent the core cpi increased by
six percent that's ahead of expectations
expectations were for five point nine
percent so just a little bit above but
above again and that's important because
the trajectory of core inflation is
supposed to be cooling down the fed
can't say oh this is all just because of
volatile food volatile energy those
things will come back no housing what
you buy at the store what you're paying
when you get in retail goods all of
those things those prices are staying
elevated as well and coming in higher
than economists expected now we did come
down a little bit on that core index
from april april was 6.2 percent we were
at six percent this month so a little
bit of of of some good news there
if you want to look at it that way but
certainly a lot to think about for the
federal reserve and remember we will be
here i hope you'll be with me right
after the fed meeting four o'clock p.m
on wednesday we'll be breaking down
everything fed chair jerome powell said
we'll be talking about the decision
we'll be talking about the market
reaction speaking of the market reaction
let's let's take a look wsj.com what
we're seeing from the markets uh the
two-year yield rose up above 2.9 percent
uh that's that's a big huge massive jump
if you're looking at the price chart
it's just whoop jumping up like that uh
the 10-year yield stay in staying pretty
calm still right around 3.05 percent but
we did see the stock market tumble right
now we're seeing the dow down by close
to one and a half percent uh the s p 500
also down a little more than one and a
half percent and the nasdaq uh in the
and again those these are those futures
prices so once the market opens that
could break even lower or maybe come
back a little bit but those futures on
the nasdaq down almost two percent
closing in on that negative two percent
level
um so let's take a step back let's talk
a little bit about expectations i told
you how expectations had been rising
consistently again at the beginning of
the live stream today and thank you guys
again for tuning in those of you who are
out there that expectations for cpi
started about 7.2 percent that would
mean that inflation had cooled down
there in april and had taken a
significant leg down in may uh we did
not see that but also before this report
was released
economists were revising that higher so
the trend is not our friend right now if
if you're looking for prices to start
coming down or at least level off at a
reasonable pace we are not there
this is higher than the recently revised
expectations much higher again we are
8.6 that is that's significant
long-term inflation expectations that's
the big question here um how much does
this report exp change the long-term
inflation expectations if you've tuned
in here on market takes i've been
talking about how around the end of may
right about that may 20th time you saw
market expectations for inflation start
to really meaningfully fall and you saw
longs on the 10-year break-even rate
five-year five-year forward rate
basically what those mean is what the
market predicts based on what people are
buying and what they're selling so the
10-year break-even rate that just breaks
out what investors are getting paid for
those bonds versus what they're getting
paid for inflation protection and the
the higher goals of means the more
expectations there are for higher
inflation so that 10-year break-even
rate had had dipped down to about 2.55
percent in late may it had been ticking
back up we still weren't to the levels
that we had gotten to uh earlier in the
year and around that april time when
folks were really expecting inflation to
just break out and go through the roof
long term do we start moving back there
do we move to new highs for long-term
inflation expectations
and does that mean that the fret the fed
starts to lose credibility with
investors the biggest takeaway i think
you could come come away with from this
report is clearly the market had
believed the fed had said okay the fed's
going to get inflation rained in it's
going to come down we peaked in march
and there were also some worries growing
worries about inflation
do we start to go back there where
now folks are saying wow fed doesn't
have this thing under control
we've really got to be worried about
longer term inflation inflation staying
at these high levels for quite some time
and what does that mean
fed rate hike expectations had also
started to diminish you saw
the market predicting the fed was going
to raise rates to two and a half percent
or so in late may
now they're predicting after this after
this number came out this morning on cpi
fed's gonna do about two point seven
five percent uh now there is over a
fifty percent chance the fed raises
rates to three percent according to fed
fund futures markets if you look at the
fomc fedwatch tool provided by cme group
so 50 more than a 50 chance the fed
raises rates to 3
that is that's the highest that rates
have been in a very long time and this
puts the chances of a 75 basis point
rate hike that's triple the pace that
the fed normally raises rates at back on
the table if you remember a couple of
months ago fed chair jerome palace said
75 basis points that's not something
we're actively discussing not something
we're talking about maybe they have to
now because inflation is not doing what
they predicted it would and what they
said they expected it it would um
you know really this this disrupts the
current narrative that's the big picture
the narrative was we're going to be
higher for longer expect inflation to be
higher than than it normally is for a
longer period of time but we peaked in
march at 8.5 and now we're coming down
this report throws off all of that the
fed's gonna have to do a lot of analysis
and we're not going to hear from them
because they're in their blackout period
from now until wednesday
when they when fed chair jerome powell
has this report and when the fed
releases its statement after its meeting
so the fed is going to meet
next week on tuesday and wednesday we'll
get that press conference on wednesday i
hope you'll be here with us right here
on market takes as we break down all
that and talk about the market reaction
and what's going on out there everywhere
in the markets
um
man the stock stock market not taking
this well but not as poorly as as it
could have been you know the dow still
hanging in there even the nasdaq closing
in on that negative two percent is not
as bad as things could have been
given what this report means and the
gravity of this report we'll see once
investors get into the office and get in
those desks once all the algos can fully
go at full bore
what the market takes away from this
report but definitely a game changer for
the market and if you're a bond investor
if you're in the treasury market whew
things just got a lot more exciting like
i said that two year yield just spiked
up over two percent again we could start
to see an inversion where expectations
if folks start pac if folks start
pricing in a recession over the long
term where that 10-year yield starts to
decline below that two-year yield and
where expectations for federal reserve
monetary policy get higher than
expectations for the long-term economy
that would produce another yield curve
inversion remember we saw that already
earlier this year go check out my video
if you haven't yet that's on the channel
and
and that could be another sign that more
folks are starting to price in a
recession because we are not seeing a
lot of movement this morning on that
10-year treasury yield which normally is
a is a good sign but today
i don't know if inflation is picking
back up that could mean the federal
reserve is going to have to hike us into
a recession or that a recession may
already be priced into the market
um
listen thank you guys all for tuning in
that's going to do it for me uh i am
dmra bowen uh this is my channel i
appreciate you guys tuning in here on
youtube and being with me we are going
to do this again like i said after the
federal reserves meeting on wednesday we
will be here 4 p.m live i hope you all
will tune in and be with us for that
and we're going to break down everything
that this report taught us about
what the fed what the fed took away and
what they said and what they're going to
be doing moving forward what we get from
the market so i hope you'll be with us
anyway thank you guys for tuning in
today and i hope you'll be back with us
next time
you